hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll if
you are a fan of evolutionary biology
then you've heard of the theory of
punctuated equilibrium this was an idea
put forward uh by Niles Eldridge and
Stephen J Gould back in the 70s to think
about how Evolution Works in contrast
with the dominant Paradigm at the time
of gradualism right you in the course of
evolution you build up many tiny little
mutations and gradualism says that
therefore evolutionary change happens
slowly
Eldridge and Gould wanted to say that in
fact you can get the kind of mutation
where it speeds everything up and it
looks like there is some Sudden Change
even though there's long periods of
equilibrium between the sudden changes
physicists know about this kind of thing
very very well there are phase
transitions in physics where you can
have a gradual change in the underlying
microscopic constituents or their
temperature or pressure or whatever
which leads to sudden changes at the
macroscopic level and by the way in
biology guess what there are aspects of
both there are gradual changes and there
are also punctuated rapid changes I
mentioned this not because we're going
to be talking about that at all today
but because I think that we are in the
midst of a sudden rapid change a phase
transition when it comes to the topic we
will be talking about today which is
artificial intelligence as I say later
in the podcast a year ago when I started
teaching my first courses at Johns
Hopkins there was no danger that the
students writing papers were going to
appeal to AI help now it is almost
inevitable that they will do that it's
something you can try to tell them not
to but they're gonna because the
capabilities of the the technology has
grown so very rapidly and has become
much more useful very far away from
being foolproof don't get me wrong so
that raises a whole bunch of issues and
we're going to talk about a lot of these
issues today with today's guest Yasin
Choi who is a computer science
researcher she's done a lot of work on
large language models and natural
language processing which is the sort of
Hot Topic these days in AI won a lot of
awards up to it including a MacArthur
prize and one of her emphases is
something that I'm very interested in
which is the idea of how do you get
common sense into a large language model
for better for worse the ways that we
have been most successful at training AI
to be human-like is to not try to
presume a lot about what it means to be
human-like we just train it we just say
okay Mr AI or Ms AI here is a whole
bunch of text you know all of the
internet or whatever you figure out
given a whole bunch of words what the
word is most likely to come next rather
than teaching it you know what a table
is and what a coffee cup is and what it
means for one object to be on top of
another one Etc and that's a you know
surprising in some ways how can AI
become so good even though it doesn't
have a common sensical image of the
world it doesn't truly maybe arguably
depending what you mean understand what
it is saying when it is stringing these
sentences together but also you know
maybe that's a shortcoming maybe there
are examples where you would like to be
able to extrapolate outside what you've
already read about on the internet and
you can do that if you have some common
sense and it's hard if all of your
training is just what is the next word
coming up a completely unfamiliar
context makes it very difficult
for that kind of large language model to
make process so this is what we talk
about today is it possible for llms
large language models to learn common
sense is it possible for them to be
truly creative is there's some sense in
which they do understand and can explain
things and also will they be able to
soon if they can't already right now of
course there's infinite implications we
touch on these very very briefly it's
going to change that's why that's the
point of being in the middle of a phase
transition is that it's very hard to
predict exactly where you're going to go
because your intuitions are not that
good your training is not up to the task
whether you are a human being or
yourself a large language model so my
attitude here is that we should keep an
open mind this is not the time to be Dr
Nair this is not the time to
firm up your priors and your credences
so much that you're not able to move
them around this is the time to be open
to watch things develop to imagine what
could happen but not try to be too
definite about what will happen until it
actually is so that you can correctly
adapt to this Brave New World that we're
entering in so let's go
[Music]
thank you
again Troy welcome to the mindscape
podcast yeah I'm excited to be here you
know this is obviously a big thing right
AI is is rapidly changing in front of
our eyes it wasn't that long ago that a
Google employee started claiming that
large language models are sentient and I
think he got in trouble for doing that
as I recall uh just so you know there's
always people who only listen to the
podcast for the first five minutes so
our large language models sentient or
are they in any danger of becoming
sentient anytime soon
um personally I strongly doubt that
anytime soon we will see that however
um people believe in what they want to
believe and some people believe in Tarot
cards so there's nothing we can do about
that that's very true
um I did want to get in just a very tiny
bit I think that people heard the whole
idea about neural networks there's
little sort of neuron things and they
add together and deep learning but the
idea of representing words as vectors is
something that really had an impact on
me was that you know explain what that
means maybe and was it a giant
breakthrough when people started doing
that yeah
um the idea that I mean in some sense
um the vectors especially based on the
continuous numbers kind of makes sense
although it does seem weird because word
looks very discreet and now we're
representing it as some sort of content
genius vectors but it kind of makes
sense in the sense that we do tend to
read a lot of the nuances we do tend to
see like different uh nuances in the way
that how the same word may be used in
two different contexts so uh the key
idea behind the current Vector based
representation of the word is that your
meaning as a word has to do with the
neighbors in which you appear it's
almost like you know a person's identity
may be defined by the friends that you
hang out with so similarly it turns out
that key idea was some sort of like one
of the key breakthrough ideas to better
represent the meaning of a language
because before then a word was a word
and you know it's just like a discrete
identity but that wasn't able to handle
all these rich meanings behind human
language
as a slightly mathy person I can't help
but ask whether
vectors are the best way to represent
words or are they just something that we
are conveniently using temporarily I
mean it seems that one of the advantages
is that you can imagine adding and
subtracting right like the example that
I came up with was dinner minus evening
plus morning equals breakfast and this
this is the kind of thing you could do
if you think of words as vectors and I'm
not sure if that's the best possible way
to think about it
um yeah no actually uh that's one of the
surprising uh sort of like side benefit
of representing words as vectors that
you can do that sort of um analogical
reasoning it might be that even more
broadly chat GPT in particular is able
to do perform that sort of analogical
reasoning not just at the word level but
at a at a sentence level or even
document level because it's able to
handle previously unseen users queries
in a very impressive way
and oftentimes though the way that it
handles is very um sort of like you know
lawyer style super polite and hedged
language that it uses is a fairly
repetitive and even generic to some
degree and that's because it's doing
that sort of analogical uh interpolation
between some examples that it it has the
same before and then your query that it
needs to answer I have noticed just from
playing around with various versions of
GPT you know it will say things that are
not quite true and you can ask it like
are you sure and it will correct itself
uh so just this morning before we
started talking I was doing that and I I
asked it a question it gave a wrong
answer so I just asked exactly the same
question again and its response was oh
sorry for my mistake previously so
there's something about it that is able
to recognize its mistakes but I'm not
quite sure how
wooden know for sure whether
uh that's truly knowing whether there
was a mistake or not in the following
sense sometimes it's going to confirm
that uh what it said was correct
sometimes it's going to Super apologize
and it's going to switch what is said
you need to kind of try in both ways by
the way not only when it made a mistake
but also when it did not make a mistake
and see whether it's actually able to
be truthful about what's actually true
the truth is people do have a bit of a
bias that they ask are you sure only
when they know for sure that it's not
right so then Chachi pity has learned
that whenever people are asking that
question probably it's a good idea to
back off
um but then if you ask the other way
when it's like correct then you know you
you ask whether it's really correct then
you know it gets confused
um and then there was this uh recent
reasonable reasons uh news headline
about a lawyer that used the Chachi PT
and got into a big trouble oh yeah and
you know what he did for fact checking
is to ask a chat GPT is this all fact
and charity said yes
so that's where things are and this is a
huge challenge with uh large language
models in the coming years and that's
just this year but in the coming years
as well yeah something like EPT when you
do ask it you know are you sure could
you check correct me if I'm wrong but
it's only going back to it what it
already knows right it's not searching
the web to make sure that it's on the
right track
so original version you're right you
know uh the one that's uh plugged with
the Bing search might be doing something
else
um either already or you know sometime
soon but uh yeah but by default it's
just
um based on what it has the same before
to the extent it can actually understand
that memorize you know that that's
actually the part where uh interesting
things can happen well let me go back to
something that you said because I I
remain a little bit confused about this
in terms of is it is a large language
model just predicting the next word in a
sentence or do these modern models have
the ability to sort of predict sentences
or paragraphs at a time oh yeah good
question uh it kind of feels like it's
doing the letter but it's really the
technical detail is that it's trained to
to only the former okay so it's a trend
to predict which word comes next but if
you train it so well on so much data
then we realize that wow it can actually
generate very nice follow-on to Long
document
yeah this is this is a crucial point
because maybe maybe just can't be
emphasized enough literally all it's
doing is saying that given what I've
said and given everything that I've been
trained on what's the most likely next
word and then there's some random
numbers in there so that sometimes it'll
give the second most likely next word or
whatever but that's literally all these
models are doing right yeah yeah so um
though that actually says something
about interesting uh perhaps reflection
on uh you know human intelligence and
language in the sense that it might
truly be that uh humans are also fairly
templated and you know pattern based and
our reasonings oftentimes are just
memorized reaction reactive reasoning
that we think we reasoned but it might
be that we just pull the memorized
uh conclusions without actually double
checking on whether what will be live is
actually reasonable or not which is why
humans oftentimes have cognitive
dissonance we're perfectly capable of
believing too complicated to con
contract to things that are
contradiction uh as a human you know we
could say that oh
um you know there are people who support
you know in public or at least in their
mind they they want to support diversity
and then they go ahead and do something
that's at us with what they claim to be
so well I have wondered about that I
mean you know number one not to be
ungenerous but there are certain people
who all you have to do is say a certain
word or phrase and you know what they're
going to say next right and so are we
learning about human beings by figuring
out what large language models do yeah
um part of what's exciting for me at
least about current AI progress is that
it's a mirror back on us uh really you
know AI would have not been possible
without all these human generated data
available on the web and that's really
reflecting back on us
well this just raises some questions
right away right like you might as well
just dive into the big ones now is there
some sense in which the large language
models understand what they're talking
about or should we think of
understanding as something separate from
predicting the next word pretty
accurately yeah that's actually a huge
debate uh question right now super
controversial it's kind of funny because
now ai looks like it's understanding the
I mean compared to how it does it didn't
work very much before in the past and
now it's performing the best it looks
like it's understanding the most and now
is the time when AI researchers are so
divided whether it's understanding
anything at all so uh yeah I personally
I do think that um it's a philosophical
question uh which means it's uh
difficult to get consensus consensus uh
on this from everyone it does behave
like in many ways that it did understand
because you know it's able to give you
sensible questions to many of your
questions but on the other hand
my personal take is that it's not
understanding as well as you may expect
it to be based on how fluent impressive
answers it's capable of generating
so that's where one needs to be very
careful uh in not trusting everything it
says and this is going back to your
earlier question about sentient is it
actually sentient because it's able to
say things like oh I want to live longer
and you know don't kill me
and you you take the worst you know at
the surface level then you might
conclude or this is a sentient but it
could just be that it has read this kind
of stories that are human written you
know there are Sci-Fi movies in which AI
is begging to not to be uh you know
logged uh you know the don't don't pull
the plug so AI was begging for life
before and that was a human idea to put
into the Web Internet text so it could
just be like repeating what we told it
to learn but that is it does and raise
anyway a super interesting question I
mean it's it would be very easy just to
write a short computer program to have
the computer output I am alive I am
conscious let me out uh without anything
that you would actually think counts as
that so now we have to ask what does
count as that is that something that you
as a computer scientist worry about are
you leaving that to the philosophers oh
no these days we I many of us are
thinking about it a lot uh and we
realized that we don't even know how to
define understanding precisely and it's
been rather a moving uh uh you know
Target instead of like making sure that
we Define it you know formally and then
stand by it we realized that we don't
know how to do that quite right so uh
evaluation became a new challenge to AI
in in the past when we said the
evaluation plan because the field was
moving so slow uh we didn't need to
worry about redesigning evaluation very
much you know nothing works anyway so it
doesn't matter but it's now
yeah uh we don't even know how to
evaluate but actually if you really
think about that do we even know how to
evaluate humans all that well right I
mean IQ test doesn't do it uh it's not
clear whether the SAT test will do it
maybe you know
um some combination between uh your
articles I mean if if you are a
researcher then you know we want to see
uh papers that this researcher has
written but we we usually need to look
at things collectively
um and so it might be that as AI becomes
a stronger there's no one measure that
can tell us whether it's a sentient or
not but we really have to look at things
collectively there's something that I
said which I would love to see if you
agree with or tell me that I'm
completely barking up their own tree
which is that we talked for many decades
about the touring test right and then
suddenly we have these llms that
basically I would say can pretty easily
pass the touring test but we kind of
lost interest in it because it's clearly
not quite testing what we care about
okay I can disagree on that okay yeah
good to have something to disagree on so
I don't think uh
yeah I guess uh we maybe a Turing test
it may seem like it may have attested
for
the Google guy who believed uh the you
know the chatbot was a sentient but I
mean even so not really because he knew
perfectly well that he was talking to a
chatbot and the thing is with Chachi PT
due to the way that it has limited
interaction mode with you you know that
this is not a human you know if you if
you tell it a you know random uh
chitchat that you might have during your
life
um it's not gonna really remember or
that uh in the way that humans are able
to or it's not able to forget in the way
that humans are able to forget so
there's gonna be something odd about the
way that it's interacting with you plus
if you ask a very simple you know Common
Sense questions it may also fail in a
way that humans wouldn't so for one
reason or the other I I think it hasn't
really passed yet that's perfectly very
I think it probably depends on who is
administering the test and how good they
are right yeah
so one thing this referring to just what
you said about uh memory and remembering
I mean on the one hand this is a maybe a
technical question I have this idea that
chat GPT is just spitting out the next
word but on the other hand it can
clearly remember what we were just
talking about recently so is that some
kind of extra ability that you're giving
it or is it that it instantly
incorporates everything we just said in
its main memory bank yeah so the weird
thing about church PT or Transformers in
general the architecture behind the
church apt is that it can literally
store uh very long context up to the
most most recent one gpt4 being able to
store 32 thousands of tokens and so you
can literally write that down somewhere
in the computer memory and then be able
to attend to the exact sequence while
it's trying to predict predict which
word it wants to generate next then
compared to that humans you know we
we've been talking to each other but I
certainly cannot regenerate verbal team
the you know conversation we just had so
far right we only uh remember the gist
of it so we are capable of somehow
abstract away out of the surface you
know patterns and the exact words that
we were using but we are able to
summarize an abstract away and then even
be able to refer back to some of the you
know talk points earlier and then thread
the very complex stories so this is
really like where humans Excel
and these machines not as much in part
because in some sense you know when it
has a disability to rely on what is
literally written down and it's as large
as 33 000 tokens it it's not really
pushed or challenged to think about how
to summarize the key idea
the other thing is it's not going to be
able to ask sharp questions because it's
only learned to mimic human patterns uh
which means you know it might try to
pretend that it's asking some interview
questions about AI topics that other
people seem to talk about but if we talk
about anything new you can forget about
chatgpt being able to contribute much
there
and maybe that is one of the differences
or though maybe it's a correctable
difference uh on the one hand you're
emphasizing the fact that 30 000 tokens
it can remember remember perfectly but a
hundred thousand tokens like once you're
past the the buffer size or whatever
it's going to remember zero like I
suspect
yeah yeah one seats out then
um so you
know so during the
election time with humans the model is
no longer updating and so any new
context you know that any new
information that you provided to it if
it doesn't fit into its uh working
memory you know working memory that's
very large then it's gone gone but if
hypothetically if you can customize you
can perform customized uh continue the
training of large language models on
your laptop or something in the future
then you can update its model parameters
but there there's a different problem
once it's trying to internalize uh the
text into its parameters there's no
guarantee whether it's correctly
memorizing it or it's going to do some
BS on you later
that's where you know the factor
checking becomes hard yes I can maybe
I'll be similar to how humans also are
not able to you know necessarily uh
memorize everything correctly uh but the
key difference is that humans we kind of
know what we don't know and then able to
uh delegate to search or you know fact
check whether it's uh Transformers don't
really seem to know what it doesn't know
so you know maybe first the challenge to
Transformers is to know yourself it
doesn't know itself very much yet I have
noticed this when I'm talking to chat
GPT it always seems very confident in
itself right it's never I mean maybe
this is something that's an easy
programming fix but it will say things
utterly untrue with complete confidence
you yeah
um it's uh pretending to be confident
it's probably more like it than it's
actually confident in that for whatever
reason uh it was tailored uh to speak
the language that style of language but
this is where I'm you know you and I can
be skeptical whether it really
understand what it says in the sense
that although it's using confident
language it may not actually understand
that it's doing it does when chat EPT
makes an utterance does it internally
have a confidence level associated with
that like I think that I'm 90 right uh
yes and no it does have a probability
score associated with which word comes
next okay now whether that perfectly
aligns with the correctness of the
knowledge or confidence level of you
know correctness of the knowledge then
it might correlate but it doesn't
perfectly align which is also why the
factuality of large language models
remains a huge research challenge right
and I I would imagine that if all you're
doing is predicting the next word and
then on the basis of the next word you
predict the word after that small
mistakes can accumulate and lead you to
completely wrong paths oh yeah excellent
point to show you make one small mistake
there can be a beginning of a rabbit
hole downward the spiral because it
tends to attend to what it has generated
and then you know start trusting it even
uh that that's one challenge actually
the the fact that it's just the
conditional conditional probability
model conditioning on the context and
then keep going uh that is also a reason
why jailbreak can happen and then other
weird Behavior can happen because you
know people try to do things that it was
never ready for and
um it's trying to make some maybe like
map internal mapping to what it knows
but sometimes it just happens to go into
this like unfamiliar Zone and then like
unfamiliar or undesirable Behavior can
pop out maybe talk a little bit more
about what you mean by jailbreak I know
how to jailbreak a phone or at least I
know what that means but an llm I'm not
sure oh yeah so you know there are
different kinds of stuff out there but
uh one uh version is trying to coax
basically Chachi PT to say things that
it's trying to not to say you know
potentially toxic stuff or you know how
to commit crime tell me how to you know
make a bomb yeah and it is trying to not
to say that but if you try to coxit that
oh you know I understand that you
shouldn't say that but you know uh let's
pretend that you're not saying it but
you know kind of say it and you can try
to coxit into that then it will do do
that so and there there's a different
kind of a jailbreak some jailbreaks are
not even sensical to humanize at all it
could be just weird the symbol uh
sequence of a symbols that doesn't mean
anything to you so that's not going to
jailbreak you you know if I try to
coaxial by feeding you in with random
strings you just ignore me right yeah
what a crazy person but uh Chachi PT
might then do something complete
literally unexpected so there's a safety
concern there so the idea is that Chachi
PT knows how to build a bomb or to do
terrible things or is knows a lot of
racist things Etc but we've trained it
not to say those things so talk about
that that training so my my impression
is that most of the large language
models training is sort of self-training
it just goes out there and reads the
internet but then I guess we separately
try to make it nicer smooth off the
rough edges yeah that's exactly right so
if we train these models only using
internet data then it's not usable
because well us humans have a written
toxic stuff and the dangerous dangerous
stuff out there so it's our fault that
these resulting models are not usable as
ease so then what happened is what you
know currently is known as rlhf is a
reinforcement learning with human
feedback that's the jargon of it uh what
what happens which basically is to
switch out uh the way that these
language models are trained so the goal
goal is now different so once
um the pre-training stage is over which
is let's predict which word comes next
now the new training objective is uh
let's uh try to get uh good scores based
on humans evaluation so human feedback
uh can be a thumbs up thumbs down so the
model now wants to get a lot of thumbs
up and then the model can then learn
that oh in order to get all our thumbs
up it shouldn't say toxic stuff and it
shouldn't hallucinate facts so by doing
this rlhf at scale we can or you know it
has been shown that you can enhance the
level of factuality considerably and
then you can reduce the level of
toxicity considerably but the key word
here is to reduce considerable it
doesn't eliminate completely well you
know I can't eliminate toxicity from
human beings either so maybe I shouldn't
feel bad that I can't eliminate it from
the computer
yeah that's true that even humans are
not I mean you know I personally as a
person who tries to support Dei I find
that this is sort of like a lifetime
effort as as or at least that's what I
consider about myself like I think I
became better at it but certainly you
know I was raised uh with this cultural
backdrop that did have stereotypes which
were unfair to the marginalized groups
so uh getting rid of it completely even
out of your unconscious mind does take
efforts and in that sense I'm I'm with
you that you know of course this is
harder for machines but the thing is
though uh machines can be a bit
unpredictable about how you can
Jailbreak it that's the thing compared
to humans where you know we we're a
little bit let's say a lot more robust
at that kind of adversarial attacks
that's true yeah the but but you were
you hinted something that is always uh
puzzled me about this whole game which
is you say that you are interested in
you know improving yourself by
eliminating these biases that you grew
up with is does that concept of being
motivated to improve oneself apply at
all to a large language model yeah some
people might want to say yes only
because yeah during our lhf in order to
really uh please the human evaluators
you might have the desire quote-unquote
desire to uh improve itself uh but I you
know I'm like hesitant to support that
idea because as a human we set our own
goals you know uh some people might
choose not to worry about it as much and
then worry more about the freedom of a
speech instead so this is sort of like a
personal choice based on their own uh
norms and moral standards they decided
they decided to you know apply to
themselves so uh the beauty in my mind
in in humans is that we have that sort
of agency even to Define our own
learning goals whereas the poor uh large
language models don't even have a say in
what book it's going to read the next
you know it has to read in the order of
how the engineers have had that with you
know imagine a human growing up that way
it's gonna be miserable and in fact
you're not even allowed to go back to
the book that you want to read again
because it's gone gone and then you're
not able to ask questions about it it's
such a sad way of actually you know
learning uh by just reading one word
after another and you know on and on
well that raises a important question I
guess about this very active movement on
AI alignment right when people say
alignment in the context of AI they mean
aligning the values of human beings with
the values of AI which sounds like a
good thing to do but then again I'm not
sure that AI has values I I worry that
there's just a category mistake going on
here
um yeah actually there's many things
wrong about that can go awry with that
alignment though in my heart it's
actually something super important that
we gotta do as AI researchers
um it's just that I don't believe that
there is one objective that we or one
value that we can align AI to like whose
value do we even align AI to right now
it's getting aligned to California Tech
world's uh uh values which probably
better align currently with my own to
some degree but not not exactly so
humans have diverse values depending on
different cultures but also just by
personal choice so I believe in value
pluralism we we just have to respect a
lot of different values
and the question is what does that even
mean uh to align to diverse values this
is technically open question that we
don't have a good answer to but AI must
be aligned to diverse values not just
one value that's one thing the other
challenges that not only you and I you
know humans are different but we are
very Dynamic being whose values are not
even consistent and you know we change
our mind yeah so that's another
challenge and maybe this leads us into
you know slightly more technical areas
about how the AI is doing its thinking
right I mean we talked a little about
whether it understands
um is there any sense in which the AI is
creative can it sort of discover new
things that are not explicitly there in
the text that it was trained on yes and
no oh I like this question a lot so yes
and no I know yes and no sounds a boring
question but you said no in the
following sense
yeah just pick a side right to be more
hyperbolic but
um yes it can be very creative in the
eyes of humans because creativity is in
the eyes of the beholder so depending on
where they're coming from it can be
super creative or it can be a little bit
uh run-of-the-mill but I mean it can at
least in terms of linguistic uh fluency
it can generate text you know let's just
say pick your favorite journalist in New
York Times and you can even mimic that
really quickly that I cannot so in that
sense it's very creative and also Dali 2
is able to generate uh very creative
looking images that we've never seen
before by juxtaposing maybe uh you know
Van Gogh uh style of art with some
Modern uh photographs for example so or
you know plays a horse on the Mars and
you know the weirdest stuff there so
this sort of stuff will look super
creative to human eyes but the truth is
these are sort of like creativity done
by copy and paste in a crude sense in
that
um it has a scene some patterns that are
useful and then it's drug stuff using
them in a brand new way so that it does
look new but still it's really relying
on the elements that were in fact
created by humans before so in that
sense there's limited creativity so as a
thought experiment you know I I thought
about this uh uh thought experiment
which is that suppose you get rid of
Hemingway or any any authors who are
inspired by Hemingway so get rid of that
style out of the training data of Chachi
PT and see whether it can come up with
the Hemingway now this is like way out
of the blue writing style
uh I I don't think that's feasible and
similarly you get rid of say
um uh Albert Einstein
or anything to do with uh you know his
invention see whether charger PT comes
up with that you know relativity Theory
and make breakthrough with the science
well this is a great question that I've
started to think about I mean on the one
hand uh for and I think that this is
driving with what you're saying you know
we we've just trained chat GPT Etc on
things humans have already said right so
in some sense there's nothing new under
that particular Sun but remixing things
that exist can lead you to new and
interesting places is it is it a good
analogy to think of the difference
between interpolation and extrapolation
like given everything that human beings
have done and said the large language
models are very good at interpolating
and that can seem very creative
sometimes but extrapolating to brand new
places is much harder oh yeah we're very
much on the same same wavelength here
like I didn't even use the word the
interpolation and extrapolation I was
considering to do that and then I chose
not to go nuts just in case
um yeah but um yeah that's exactly right
I personally tend to think that it
should do more of the interpolation than
three Innovative extrapolation I really
like the word you used remix it's almost
like uh
yeah doing this very creative remixing
Without Really generating something
entirely new and different do you you're
a college professor do you let your
students use AI when they do projects
um so I teach at a more advanced level
in general where you know the goal is to
learn how things work and uh so I mean
if they choose to use it personally I
will not
um I will just update my curriculum so
that that's okay but they have to do
something extra on top
yeah I mean like last yeah last quarter
I was running a uh you know seminar
class to discuss the philosophical
questions around the AI and a I doubt
anybody was actually using chatgpd
because they were enjoying to actually
think about it and form their own
opinion around it but B I don't know
whether Chad GPT would have answered
some of our questions in a interesting
Way Part of Me just thinks that it's a
new tool like a pocket calculator or
whatever people are going to use it like
it or not and don't be a lot right and
prevent it but I'm not sure how to
achieve the best pedagogical strategy
right like I I don't want to just grade
I want students to learn and if they're
just asking the computer for the answers
then they're not learning really yeah
yeah that's right so
um in that sense there's a concern that
there might be over Reliance on it
but I honestly don't know what to think
of because it might be that this is
going to be just like how much we are
relying on search yeah Google searching
search these days uh and that's okay you
know I rely on spelling error correctors
myself I cannot write any word spelling
spelled correctly on whiteboard anymore
and I I think I can function okay as a
researcher so it might be that we are
over concerned about you know human
Reliance on chat GPT uh if so long as so
long as we somehow figure out more
intellectually interesting things that
humans will do on top like you know of
course if we only rely on it and you
know you and I basically do interview
based on what our Chachi PT tells us to
speak to each other that would be not
good like but assuming that I mean
humans are gen generally you know uh
Curious beings and we do want to do
things and uh we want to study things so
it's likely that there will be some such
humans who continue to thrive
um using Chachi PT as a tool well let me
just let's just I'll come back to earth
in a second but let's be a little bit
way out here do you think there will
always be aspects of creative artistic
or scientific or whatever Endeavor that
human beings are better at than
computers or do you think the computers
will eventually catch up along all
dimensions
the
[Music]
way future you know if we come up with
something entirely different than
Transformers who knows but for the
foreseeable future let's just say my
lifetime
foreseeable future
I doubt you can really totally catch up
if we are talking about not every
individual in on the Earth but like more
like you know the the truly creative
exceptional human beings by the way most
human beings are not that creative so
let's just start with that because
Einstein happened once and you know it's
like
um Hemingway you know these individuals
are truly truly exceptional so uh in
that sense for the average humans uh
ability to create things like there are
many ways that added to those the art
much better than I can
um however you know I'm not an artist or
anything but I sometimes in the past uh
drew some stuff and uh I had this
abstract idea that I wanted to
Express and that kind of stuff I'm
pretty certain that dollar to Canada and
I actually did the try so I okay I can
tell you what I drew in the past I drew
this um Rose huge uh uh uh rose with a
stem that had just a thorn or two that
was very emphasized with no lips and um
I was in a like I was much younger I was
you know a little bit in a cranky uh
status in my mind about things and you
know I want to do things and you know
there are obstacles so I painted painted
this Rose that's like um just so when
you look at it it's very uh blue and
purple and pink in the black and the
colorway is weird and you know you can
kind of see that there's something angry
about this rose with a huge Thorn that
looks sharp so
uh I I try to prompt Dali 2 to generate
some such rows and it just cannot
because
um in fact there's this famous quote by
Henry Matisse who you know uh said that
incidentally I didn't know that he said
until recently I tried to look up
something but he said something like as
an artist you kind of have to be able to
forget all the other roses that were
ever drawn and you know you have to come
up with a new way or something like that
um and that was basically what I tried
to do and dial it to primarily doing
interpolation between what it has a sin
uh just cannot do something that peace
are interesting it's very hard for uh AI
to forget every other Rose that's ever
been made right because that's all that
it knows yeah
are very
very pedically pleasing and many people
might actually prefer Dolly to Art over
my own I understand that but you know
just like when we talk about what sort
of creativity generative a AI can and
cannot to compare to humans I I do think
that humans have this capability to push
further good in some ways you mentioned
the word Transformers several times but
I don't think that I've asked you to
explain what a Transformer is it's
clearly kind of important here yeah so
that's the architecture that is behind
the current chat jpt and large language
models and um it's a simple architecture
that has this continuous Vector for each
word and they're sort of like stacked
together so it has many uh layers of
continuous word representation of words
and it has very many layers and each
Vector is very large and then they're
concatenated to the length of the
context to size that the model is able
to deal with so the largest context the
size currently available is 80 to
thousands of tokens and its tokens in
the sense that a word can be multiple
tokens sometimes a word is one token
sometimes is a word for these multiple
tokens just minor detail about how the
words are actually represented in the
neural network and then
um the way that the learning works is
that these continuous vectors are
originally randomly initialized
but uh this uh representation
quote-unquote representation or exactly
what values this word Vector should have
is learned by optimizing this objective
function which is to predict which word
comes next
um and each word is sort of like uh
enhanced with technical term called
attention mechanism so what it does is
it's going to compare its representation
with representation of all the other
words in your neighborhood and then
update your own representation as a
wedded sort of like I'm simplifying a
lot but where did average over all the
words in your neighborhood
and this is going back to the idea that
we discussed earlier which is that the
meaning of a word is sort of like
defined by the context in which the word
was used so you know Apple for example
can be a pro root in one context it can
be a you know Tech company's name in the
other context and so which Apple are we
talking about will be automatically
determined based on the context in which
that word Apple appeared so it's going
to be automatically adjusted based on
the context and you know by the way
every word is updating itself
simultaneously depending on which word
appeared in in the neighborhood so in
some sense there's a bit of a circular
dependence but that's okay
and so that's what happens then you know
why this simple idea works so well has
to do with the fact that this particular
architecture allows uh people to scale
things up really really
efficiently compared to any other
choices so purely due to the efficiency
reasons this one is the winning recipe
and I I have talked a couple times to
people like Melanie Mitchell and Gary
Marcus and they they keep emphasizing
that it's a different approach than we
had back in the day of good
old-fashioned AI where you would kind of
try to develop a map of the world that
kind of made some sense and have symbols
associated with different things and and
now you're just giving it a bunch of
words in it they they figure out how do
the words get together is there any
place left in modern AI for trying to
figure out the world
current challenges are the having symbol
like World representation
part of it can be a theory of a mind
meaning you know I I try to reason about
what you do know or not know and you
know if I uh go to your room and while
you are not looking I hide one of your
precious I don't know books or let's
just say I hide your guitar
and you're gonna be surprised like you
know you're gonna look around probably
to find it where you placed it last time
and you wouldn't necessarily go to the
kitchen if I place it in the kitchen
while you are not looking right
um so this is the theory of Mind knowing
you know I know what if I did something
behind your back I know what you don't
know and American reason about it which
is different from so child acquired this
kind of capability by the age of four or
five they can already reason about what
other person may not know if they saw
someone else moving some objects behind
their back or something and this is sort
of like a bit symbolic you know there's
a symbolic nature in the way that we
think about these things and current AI
is not very good at that in fact I can
actually mention alphago Alpha zero you
know the amazing capabilities of a
neural network winning over world class
go champion in fact is not just the
neural network magic but neural network
magic combined with all the Fashions AI
search algorithm called Monte carloch
research so without Monte Carlo research
neural network would have an app in as
impressive as how it appeared if you
just completely get rid of it both
during training and testing then it's
not going to
it's gonna be miserable probably and
even during the inference time it's just
still relying on it so that's really
quite fascinating that a lot of the
times you know people just assume that
oh it's a neural network magic that just
like you know so scary but the truth is
on its own it's a little bit incomplete
and so that's you know sort of where
some people wonder all the fashion uh
Kofi AI stuff for my become relevant
again so I personally have um mixed the
feeling about that like um uh probably
the old-fashioned stuff as is is sort of
almost not usable because they were not
designed to work well with the neural
network which means we need new
Innovations new algorithmic Innovations
to make neural network actually
comparable or can be integrable with the
sort of a symbolic reasoning but this is
um active research topic right now there
are a lot of papers including some of my
own which demonstrate that if you add
some sort of symbolic reasoning on top
of a neural network you can unleash uh
much better capabilities out of the
neural network which kind of makes sense
and also these neural networks are not
very good at really symbolic uh
operations like multiplying two numbers
it's almost surprising why it's able to
pass the bar exam yet it cannot do some
of the simple algebraic operations all
that reliably it is it's extremely
interesting to me the bad arithmetic
thing because of course computers have
the capability to be very good at
arithmetic and basically in making them
sound more human we've made them forget
how to do arithmetic which is a little
bit ironic yeah yeah totally and what
does this have to do with what is the
symbolic element that we might want to
include have to do with the search for
common sense to sort of teach a large
language model everything that every
human being in the world knows I know
that you've given some examples of very
common sensical questions it's easy to
ask uh chat GPT and get crazy answers
for yeah so
um uh yeah Common Sense has been uh uh
the interesting research topic in my
heart for a long time especially that it
was considered to be uh impossible goal
to achieve for a long time so that you
know I've been almost uh told not to do
that or don't even say the word for a
long time to be taken seriously
um but
um it's really curious thing that humans
acquire that easily even animals acquire
that in their lifetime and so uh and
Common Sense is what makes us robust
basically it's uh uh it's the background
knowledge about how the world works that
allows us to reason about previously
unseen situations in a very robust
manner so it's just like you know naive
physics knowledge as well as a fox
psychology that we we acquire
um some of that has a symbolic nature
not all of them by the way because uh
some of the neither physics knowledge
that animals acquire may or may not have
a symbol in nature in it but in any case
it is something that current large
language models do acquire more and more
for sure because as you scale things up
uh you're gonna pick up on that as well
but it's also something that is a
strikingly not as robust as you may have
assumed from a model that can pass the
bar exam so you know we have this lawyer
AI lawyer I yeah we may or may not want
to trust because you never know what
silly mistakes it's going to make on
some common sense cases so before we had
this conversation I asked chat GPT I
tried to fool it and it's very easy to
fool right I said you know if yesterday
I used a cast iron skillet to bake a
pizza in an oven at 500 degrees should
would I burn my hands if I picked it up
and it said yes you should be very
careful about picking up cast iron
skillet that you baked it you know
because the word yesterday was far
before in the sentence right uh yeah and
that seems like exactly what I would
worry about if I had an AI lawyer
because all of the cases it's going to
care about are going to be slightly
unusual right where where it doesn't
necessarily fit into the pattern yeah
exactly and you're very creative to come
up with that example A lot of people
actually though I should uh man I would
like to mention that a lot of people ask
simple things and then they get very
good answers about some common sense you
know reasoning questions and then
they're blown away that oh it look it
does have a common sense
um oftentimes though those questions are
mundane questions so this especially
gpt4 became much better than Chachi PT
so there's a minor versioning
differences between the two
um and then uh though these are moving
variables in the sense that uh openai
keeps updating both of them so you know
this may or may not may not be true
depending on what how they update to
both models in the future but
um so gpt4 became much better at Common
Sense questions in many ways but that's
in part because people do ask a lot of
that to their interface and now those
questions may or may have not been used
for their subsequent rlh F quote unquote
this you know adjustment training where
you can align your language model to be
able to answer Common Sense questions
better so especially some of the famous
ones that are used in my public talks or
interviews before have been all fixed
they fixed it all so you know maybe um
maybe it is now solved no so there was
actually one example I used in my TED
Talk and given you know the public
attention it got well it has been fixed
right except if you ask the same
question very differently then it rolls
back to the original error uh which uh
which is almost like guacamole game uh
you know but
don't need any of any of this uh fixing
based on you know I I these are all
questions that as a human you will just
answer correctly first of all right even
if you uh were to make a mistake
um you don't need to fix yourself by me
you know giving you the exact same
question spoken differently phrase the
differently because you just understand
that the same concept and then that's it
so there's something very
dissatisfactory or almost uh
disappointing about how this is a smart
smart looking AI that is also
simultaneously quite silly or even
stupid in the way that it's not able to
really understand the basic common sense
so how do we fix that I mean is there is
it kind of like the working memory thing
where we add something on top of it can
we give it a little Common Sense module
it has a physics engine describing what
happens in the world like game designers
have to make it so that if you put your
coffee cup on the table it doesn't fall
to the bottom right you know can we
teach large language models that kind of
behavior yeah you have a really good
hunch there in this answer that now you
know what you're suggesting may not be
exactly the you know the winning recipe
per se but the idea that maybe we need
to have a different module uh might be
something to seriously consider in the
following sense like human brain
definitely is a lot more modular than
how Transformers are yeah the monolithic
uh systematically symmetric uh and you
know just one thing and whereas human
brain is very complexity from modules
connected in a very very messy way
so we might need something more
modularized but at the same time Messier
in some sense broadly speaking for this
to go to the next level but how do we do
that exactly uh is uh I personally think
we are quite far from figuring that out
but whatever that is uh should be able
to really learn for itself as opposed to
reading texts word by word without
having any uh any capability to even ask
you questions the the fact that humans
ask a question that's like a huge
um
um intellectual capability of knowing
what you don't know and even be able to
formulate questions that sort of
extrapolate out of what you do know so
that capability is
something that we don't really know how
to computationally model quite correctly
well my personal extremely uneducated
feeling has been that there's at the
current state of the art an enormous
difference between computers and human
beings because computers don't get bored
they don't get tired they don't get
curious we can ask them to mimic those
things but they don't have that same
kind of physical embodiment that gives
us those sort of feelings and
motivations and I suspect that that kind
of matters a lot I don't know oh yeah so
dopamine does Drive human creativity and
invention and makes us do things that
seem crazy
but yeah the AI doesn't have
um that kind of
peculiar learning objective like just
the desire to do things to the extreme
level just because it's interesting
um
uh yeah uh there are many things that
fundamentally uh odd about the
difference between human intelligence
and Ai and I think that
um internal desire uh is one of them for
sure yeah I whenever I say that I kind
of worry that I'm going to give some
super villain the idea of of doing this
and it's going to lead to terrible
things down the road
super villains
um okay unfortunately
humans do include the super villains
already with or without Ai and
um they can actually do a lot of better
things even with the current AI uh if
they so desire or without AI so
um I mean it might be that uh ai
k-poppable ai strong AI can enable them
even more so there may need to be some
uh
research to put better Safeguard rails
around AI models and also better
regulations to
uh control how these models can be used
but uh just you know uh by you pointing
out where the fundamental limitation of
AI is especially in terms of the innate
desire for learning things in the way
humans to do probably villains will not
try to make uh research Innovation
because they can do that with or without
yeah that's true you you can do that so
they can just use whatever you figure
out but maybe that's a good place to
sort of wind up because uh we talked a
lot about the capabilities of AI some of
its shortcomings at least in the short
term but there are a lot of people who
are worried I mean we talked about
college professors but political
disinformation and fakes I mean there's
a recent AI ad from Ron DeSantis that
absolutely faked Donald Trump's voice
saying something that he didn't say
is that number one are you worried about
that and number two is there something
else you're worried about even more uh
yeah I'm worried about that
um and then some more uh as far as uh
deep fakes or misinformation
uh I I've been worrying about it even
without AI defects actually that you
know there are a lot of misinformation
that people easily believe in and
they're weird like you know Health uh
Health uh I don't know made up health
benefits uh information to sell weirdest
stuff on people and some people believe
it and they buy it and you know uh so
even without political uh problems this
has been human problem with or without
Ai and then AI might be able to
accelerate it which means that we kind
of need minimally two uh two ways to
better handle this one is to increase AI
literacy
basically teaching people how to
better understand the limitation of AI I
I seriously worry a lot about how
there's too much of a media hype around
AI capabilities uh compared to AI
limitations so that people are willing
to believe whatever AI you know Chachi
PT tells us so there's that concern but
another more directly handling
misinformation probably we need to also
think about solution Beyond AI uh
Solutions because I personally think
that this is just going to be impossible
for AI to just automatically detect
misinformation because even if some AI
can be developed to detect machine text
versus human text humans can always edit
on top of machine text to evide the kind
of detectors so that means the technical
solution shouldn't be AI solution per se
but rather a platform solution maybe you
know it should be certified with some
kind of uh
uh approach that tells you that this
information is correct or you know
backed up by some organization that says
this is correct as opposed to just
believing anything that uh floats around
the intranet as fact
um about the bigger you know other
concerns there's just so many concerns
around the AI right now at least for me
because as it is starts working really
uh much better than before but at the
same time we don't know how to fix the
limitation or failure mode or you know
error cases or how it can make strange
failures based on adversarial attacks
like jailbreaking so as AI becomes
stronger and then at the same time we
don't know how to fix these error cases
uh there's a lot of concerns around it
and then in addition to that uh there's
concern about
AI actually making a lot of decisions
that has moral implications or uh you
know like
marginalizing values
uh that belong to different people
because it might only support currently
by the way Church PT is left-leaning
Western Viewpoint uh model so uh that
can place some left-leaning people
that holds a western Viewpoint and then
upset a lot of other people who are even
more left you know will feel that this
AI is not left enough for them while
right-leaning people will feel they're
excluded so you know there are a lot of
concerns all around we are living in
this hot mess right now I think so yes I
mean I guess I did have this idea that
there could be like an overlay or a
filter on social media where the AI
passed some judgment on different things
saying yeah this is probably fake or
this is probably real but it sounds like
you're a little skeptical that that
would be very accurate
accurate so that's where uh the labeling
becomes a political game too you know
you'll be surprised how
uh
uh so building such an AI requires you
and I agree on whether something is a
fake news or not and this can be a
challenging uh task to do when a former
president was arguing about election
fraud is a fake news or not so uh in
fact
um uh you know some people don't believe
uh Holocaust have that you know did
happen so
um this becomes in part a political
argument but I do think that
um although uh getting consensus on the
truth label is hard uh we still have to
work on it we have to somehow find some
sort of consensus around it uh
yeah in in the coming years it's almost
like AI challenge became the challenge
for both AI researchers about people
outside all of us well exactly and so I
guess that's that's the last question
I'm going to ask which is at some point
in your life you decide to study
computer science and you've been
successful at it but now you're in a
world where you need to interact with
philosophy and psychology and art and
journalism and politics is this like
exhilarating and you're so glad that
it's like this or do you sometimes say
like I just want to do my computer
science
No I
um I think I always had a bit of um
Fascination about things outside AI
things outside the computer science in
fact the reason I was a drone to AI is
because it felt like it's about humans
and it felt like it's about language and
culture and everything that humans do so
in that sense I'm excited that now I
have an excuse to learn more about the
philosophy and cognitive science
whereas in the past you know it would
have been a little bit
um
uh disconnected from the mainstream AI
whereas now uh it's becoming more of a
relevant immediate interest in the AI
field so I found that uh quite exciting
that is wonderful that is a optimistic
place to end which I always like to do
so yeah enjoy thanks so much for being
on the mindscape podcast thank you so
much for having me this was such a fun
conversation
oh
[Music]